we now revisit the exponential random
variable that we introduced earlier and
develop some intuition about what it
represents we do this by establishing a
memorylessness property similar to the
one that we established earlier in the
discrete case for the geometric PMF
suppose that it is known that light
bulbs have a lifetime until they burn
out which is an exponential random
variable you go to a store and you are
given two choices to buy a new light
bulb or to buy a used light bulb that
has been working for some time and has
not yet
burned out which one should you take we
want to approach this question
mathematically so let us denote by
capital T the lifetime of the bulb so
time starts at time zero and then at
some random time that we denote by
capital T the light bulb will burn out
and we assume that this random variable
is exponential with some given parameter
lambda in one of our earlier
calculations we have shown that the
probability that capital T is larger
than some value little X Falls
exponentially with that value X we are
now told that a certain light bulb has
already been operating for T time units
without failing so we know that the
value of the random variable capital T
is larger than little T we're interested
in how much longer the light bulb will
be operating and so we look at capital X
which is the remaining life time from
the current time until the light bulb
burns out so capital X is this
particular random variable here and it
is equal to capital t minus little T let
us now calculate the probability that
the light bulb lasts for another little
x time unit
that is that this random variable
capital X is at least as large as some
little X that is that the light bulb
remains alive until time T plus X we use
the definition of conditional
probabilities to write this expression
as the probability that capital X is
bigger than little X on the other hand
capital X is t minus T so we write it
this way t minus T is bigger than little
X and also that T is bigger than little
T divided by the probability of the
conditioning event just write this event
in a cleaner form capital T being larger
than little t plus X and being larger
than little T again divided by the
probability of the conditioning event
and now notice that capital T will be
greater than little T and also greater
than little t plus X that is capital T
is larger than this number and this
number if and only if it is larger than
this second number here so in other
words the intersection of these two
events is just this event here that
capital T is larger than little T plus X
now we can use the formula for the
probability that capital T is larger
than something we apply this formula
except that instead of little X we have
T plus X and so here we have e to the
minus lambda T plus X divided by the
probability that capital T is bigger
than T so we use this formula but with
little T in the place of little X and we
obtain e to the minus lambda t we have a
cancellation and we're left with e to
the minus lambda X which is the final
answer in this calculation what we
observe here the probability that the
used light bulb will live for another X
time units is exactly the same as the
corresponding probability that a new
light bulb will be alive for another X
time units so new and used light bulbs
are described by the same probabilities
and they are probabilistically identical
the same differently said the used light
bulb does not remember and it is not
affected by how long it has been running
and this is the memorylessness property
of exponential random variables let us
now build some additional insight on
exponential random variables we have a
formula for the density the PDF and from
this we can calculate the probability
that T lies in a small interval for
example for a small Delta this
probability here is going to be
approximately equal to the density of T
evaluated at 0 times Delta which is
lambda times e to the 0 which is 1 times
Delta what if we're told that the line
bob has been alive for tea-time units
what is the probability that it burns
out during the next Delta time units
since I used but still alive light bulb
is probabilistically identical to a new
one this conditional probability is the
same as this probability here that a new
light bulb burns out in the next Delta
time units and so this is also
approximately equal to lambda Delta so
we see that independently of how long a
light bulb has been alive during the
next Delta time units it will have a
lambda Delta probability of failing one
way of thinking about this situation is
that the time interval is split into
little intervals of length Delta and as
long as the light bulb is alive if it is
alive at this point it will have
probability lambda Delta of burning out
during the next interval of length Delta
this is like flipping a coin once every
Delta time steps there is a probability
lambda Delta that there is success in
that coin flip where success corresponds
to having the light bulb actually burned
down and the exponential random variable
corresponds to the total time elapsed
until the first success in this sense
the exponential random variable is a
close analog of the geometric random
variable which was the time until the
first success in a discrete time setting
this analogy turns out to be the
foundation behind the Poisson process
that we will be studying later in this
course